um I was gonna say hit for you uh it's
been it's been a crazy last three or
four years
um
in terms of just like some of the
moments that you've had obviously it's
been a crazy last like 12 years for you
but
um what's up is uh is the is the King's
disease series over
I mean I you can't ever say that me and
Nas we steady work and we you know we
definitely got new music you know we all
know exactly which way it's gonna go you
know that's Nas and he do what he do but
you know when it's time I'm I'm just
gonna be available but I can't say it's
over you know I mean I was gonna say how
many artists have hit you to kind of try
to do the same thing with you because
it'd be a nice it'd be a nice premium to
have a whole man fully produced hitboy
album definitely a few you know I mean
like I did the Benny album I did a
couple different joints but I mean me
and Nas we got a different level just a
different level of a personal you know
relationship like it's just like we that
should just be working we getting there
sometimes I get in with the artists and
it just we don't get nothing with knives
we always gonna get at least a verse a
hook something done like when you pull
up so that's just the ill [__] so we we
all just making music I was gonna say I
always go back and forth between whether
I like magic or King's disease 3 the
most out of your guys's bodies of work
yeah that's that's out here that all the
time I'm a magic person exactly you
mostly be magic yeah and it's crazy
because magic is the one record that we
just woke up one day and it was just
like what the [__] yeah exactly but
what's your favorite
um I mean kd3 man I like all of them bro
I can't lie like I got special moments
that I just like feel super connected to
on every album but I feel like it's
progressively I think each project
somehow like it just kept getting better
yeah that's I mean you know I feel like
we just start gelling more like I start
getting more into my just history and
Nas music I'm from the West Coast so
it's like I didn't only grew up here in
the nas hits I was on the radio my
family super West Coast so they wasn't
playing Nas like that you know I mean so
I know I had some friends who their
family might have played knives but just
as far as my circle it wasn't you know
something that was embedded in me the
way like certain West Coast Music would
be like Snoop Dogg music or something so
I had to really learn and really study
them albums and really be like okay this
is what people like from him let me take
this and just mix it with what I do yeah
um I was gonna say you guys are you and
Alchemist put out the incredible
freestyle that went viral uh yeah
rapping over each other's Beats which I
thought was genius
I also think we don't get enough
Alchemist wrapping these days we need a
new Step Brothers out by the way but
would you guys do a whole project like
that Bros we already got one we already
got one bro we got like all slipping in
the darkness level like joints like you
know it's gonna happen when it happened
but and it's just you guys are both
rapping yeah we stacking them up like
I'll send him beats I hit send me beats
and we'll just go in send them back boom
you do a verse you do a hook like we
it's just it's ill like we're giving
each other direction just through
sending joints over and just like you
know what I mean do you guys like I
wonder how that works because like
obviously you guys are both all-time
great producers is it do you guys
collaborate on the Beats together is it
like yo this is a photo of [__] I got
this a photo shoot you got let's pick
which ones we like and then or is it
like hey yeah you have a loop he's got a
loop together we honestly is so new of a
process that we we haven't even got to
cook together yet it's just been sending
[__] back and forth but we got we got a
nice slow amount of joints already just
off that so yeah I kind kind of feel
like you what you did with that was like
the what Kendrick did with the control
freak or the control record that was my
exact sentiment you know 100 just wanted
to challenge the game and have some fun
and raise some questions that's never
like I never said [__] was whack no I
didn't other than one person yeah yeah
you know I mean but it's like I never
said the rest of them dudes was whack I
just was like can do do this I never
seen him do this you know I mean I like
that's that's all it was putting in con
put it in in context in an artistic way
did you and hit make ever have a combo
after your guys's uh online back and
forth nah
I just assumed it was like it was like
nice promotion for everybody right nah
that was great yeah for sure that was
solid I think I think you hit it on the
head because like uh who did I have oh I
had Eric Ballinger here and we were
talking about like the difference
between you guys yeah like Rick Rubin
doesn't make beats did you like
obviously I mean I feel like I'm sure he
made some of them classes Rick Rubin
says he he doesn't know how to do
anything he's there for his taste
I don't believe that I think that's the
older Rick Rubin I know he was in there
cooking something which I don't know he
said that he he doesn't make any beats
he's there for his taste and I feel like
I mean that's like kind of the lane
hitmakers and it's like you bring hit
make in because he's got an ear he's got
the writers and then you you got it all
you could take the NPC out and you could
you know there's nothing you can't touch
you know what I'm saying we're gonna
leave it at that yeah Jesus